In this lesson, you'll learn
how to create a stellar resume.
We'll start with how to make
a comprehensive spreadsheet of
all your professional experiences.
This is what we call a master resume.
Next, we'll learn how to best summarize
your professional experiences.
We'll detail how to craft compelling
bullet points that prove your unique
strengths and skills.
Since resumes are meant
to be targeted and
not show everything you've ever done,
you'll also create a targeted resume.
Using your new master resume,
you'll research a job of interest and
compose a resume for this position.
To top off all of your hard work, you'll
make sure the style and format of your
resume is up to snuff by completing a
personal review of our resume checklist.